What are you waiting for?
Dusty,
are you okay?
In the Big Door Prize,
we find Dusty with his family
on the occasion of his 40th birthday.
Whoop! Whoop!
A scooter!
Wow!
He's somebody who thinks that he has
everything he wants.
One day, this machine arrives.
What the hell?
It promises to tell people their life potential.
And for Dusty, the machine
opens up a chasm of uncertainty
as he reevaluates whether he might
actually want something more out of life.
Where'd you get it?
No idea. It just appeared like magic.
Is that right?
It's also about an entire town
going through a midlife crisis.
This machine turns everyone's life upside down.
I got dancer.
Superstar.
Male model.
Make it stop.
Some people get excited
and some people have questions.
We’re actually getting a divorce.
The Morpho inspired us.
What?
It's so fun to watch the different ways
people interpret their potential.
I got explorer.
Which obviously means sexual explorer.
Obviously.
Even in a place where people think
they know everything about everyone.
Are you flexing?
These are my relaxed arms.
When did you get so jacked dad?
Everyone has their own secret, everyone
has their own inner struggle.
Do you ever get that feeling that there’s like
a big, heavy foot on your chest?
I think that's just anxiety.
Mr. Hubbard I get that a lot.
I think what makes the Big Door Prize original
is this incredible cast of characters.
This is so different
from anything that I've worked on.
I see you out here! Let's go!
Kind of like this fantastical, funny,
but also, a really heartbreaking show.
You can let me go now.
It's an exciting time to talk about big ideas,
and this is a fantastic
comedy with a great premise.
What I hope with people when they watch,
is that they see themselves in some of these characters.
It really touches on these universal longings within all of us,
in a funny and poignant way.
If you were offered another life potential,
would you take it?